well you can see from this graph just
how quickly inflation has caught up with
wage growth at two-point-three percent
it's now at the same level as the latest
date of a pay growth which covers the
three months to January and that's
fueling concern of another cost of
living crisis or frances o'grady general
secretary the trade union congress is in
our westminster studio and sarah huyn is
the chief economist for europe a
standard chartered Sarah I'll start with
you first I mean how much of this
increase do you think is down to the
post referendum fall in the pant not
feeding into domestic price pressures
well not too much so far at the main
driver of higher inflation that was
reported today has been rising transport
costs down to higher fuel prices if we
look at how far all prices have risen
over the past year in sterling terms
they've pretty much doubled so that's
been the main driver we're starting to
see something of an impact from the
weaker pound feeding through into high
import costs but we'll probably see much
more of that to come in the coming
months what about the bank of england's
reaction to this i mean everyone's
assuming there's going to be no increase
in bank rate this year is that now back
on the table is that up for discussion
again it's certainly up for discussion
and we know that some policymakers are
feeling a little bit uneasy about
holding rates so low for such a long
time when you're facing a rise a sharp
rise in inflation but from the bank of
england's point of view the higher
inflation is a risk to the economy it
cups people spending capacity and that
could mean that growth slows and will in
which case you don't want to be raising
interest rates well frances o'grady what
would you make of what sir has just been
saying how worried are you about a rise
in Livingston squeeze on living
standards I think working families up
and down the country are worried about
that they're facing this double blow of
rising prices and no real wage increase
and of course the risk is that people go
back to building up household debt as
the only way to get by and we know what
mess that got us into last time so we
need some government action and a little
less complacency from government
ministers about what we see is
lubing living standard crisis so what
specifically then would you like to see
the government doing bearing in mind
that you know the deficit is still going
to be something like 51 billion pounds
this financial year and about the same
next year that we've got working
families all over the country facing a
real cut in their living standards and
the root of this problem is that we've
got too many insecure low-paid jobs and
too little investments that will deliver
the kind of high-skilled high paid jobs
that not just families need the country
needs Britain is still in the bottom
three of the OECD League for total
investment that needs to change we
wanted to see that change in the last
budget perhaps we'll get it in the next
one why do you think that pay
settlements look like the risk of
failing to keep up with inflation that I
think the one prescription that the
government hasn't tried is putting more
bargaining power in the hands of working
people we've seen this massive growth in
zero hours and bogus self-employment
where workers are too frightened to put
the head above the parapet and ask for a
pay rise we've seen attacks on trade
unions instead of encouraging trade
unions to grow to balance up that power
deficit a bit but also of course we've
had that pay cap or nurses firefighters
midwives a year after year they've
suffered real pay cuts and you know they
just can't carry on on that basis I
think we have a government that has
promised to serve the interests of
working people and now we need some
evidence of it so restore one way of
restoring the playing field between the
self-employed and the employ of course
was raising national insurance
contributions for the self-employed you
saying the Chancellor should have held
his nerve last week we I think we're
very clear that the real problem here is
a growth in self-employment that we
would describe as bogus where we've seen
too many employers taking workers off
employee contracts and putting them on
to self-employed contracts even though
they're controlling their work and
they're not genuinely self-employed we
would like to have seen the Chancellor
deal with that I think if you were
to reform the tax system to make it
fairer between the self employed in the
employees then you need to make sure
that the self-employed get the same
benefits and rights that employees get
and currently they don't get sick pay
they don't get holiday pay they pay for
their own training you know we would
need to see a pretty radical overhaul of
the rights the self-employed enjoy
before you hit them over the head with
tax increases so where does inflation go
from here what are your expectations for
the rest of the year we're expecting
inflation to carry on rising we think
that it will very quickly move above
three percent probably by the middle of
the year and then it's likely to stay
between two and three percent over the
next couple of years we'll continue to
see the impact of the weaker pound
feeding through to higher import prices
and that impact is going to linger on
and some people would say this is
actually a positive in some ways I mean
lord King the governor of the Bank of
England had said that a fall in the
pound the former governor he said it
fall in the pan was inevitable this was
all essential if the economy was going
to be rebalanced away from exports and
away from imports and towards exports it
certainly ought to help export exports
have become a lot more competitive as a
result and I think the expectations are
that exports will rise imports are more
expensive so that ought to slow the
growth in in imports it ought to help
our balance of payments the question is
what's happening in the rest of the
economy we've relied on consumer
spending to drive growth as Francis says
investment has been very weak recently
and if households feel that their their
incomes are squeezed either they have to
borrow more they have to draw on their
savings or they have to spend less I
think the bank of england's concern is
that households will spend less and that
could end up being a problem for the
economy worth pointing out so I mean you
are you are lest we forget European
chief economist at standard chartered I
mean we're starting to see inflation
tickle higher in in mainland Europe as
well only yes that's right and it's a
big question for the Bank of England and
for the European Central Bank both
central banks have interest rates very
low European Central Bank is due
in quantitative easing Bank of England
up until recently had a quantitative
easing package so for both banks the
question is when do you start to raise
interest rates and I think both central
banks are looking at what happens to
wages if wages accelerate that will be
the signal to start to raise interest
rates Frances well we have you here a
quick question on on unions more
generally at the moment Tom Watson
yesterday suggesting that momentum is
trying to infiltrate unite unite may
start to fund the momentum group how
would I about the consequences for the
Labour Party of that the TC isn't
affiliated to any party but what I am
care about is that we need an effective
opposition any democratic country needs
a good opposition holding the government
to account and my goodness me working
people out in the country really need a
strong opposition fighting for them
aren't making the case for good skill
jobs in the parts of Britain that need
the most is jeremy corbyn's Labour Party
not providing an effective opposition at
the moment then well I don't think it's
any secret that if a party is fighting
within itself then it's not doing the
job of opposition as well as many
working people need it to but let's be
clear that it's not just the opposition
that's got divisions I think we've seen
a fair few divisions in government too
not least over the manner of the brexit
that we have and whether this is going
to be a brexit that protects our economy
delivers good jobs protects people's
livelihoods or whether we're going to be
captured by these ultras on the back
benches in the Conservative Party who
seemed to not want any kind of good deal
with what is our most important trading
partner the EU